in this video we'll be talking about
Neiman Pig's disease which is a
lysosomal storage disorder this was
reported by Albert Niemann and Ludwig
Peak
so this particular disorder is a genetic
disorder which
compromise the body's ability to
metabolize fat such as cholesterol and
sphingolipids within the cell
so sphingomyelin and cholesterol cannot
be broken down properly or could not be
transported properly in this disease
sphingomyeline generally gets broken
down into ceramide and phosphorylcholine
with the help of the enzyme acids
sphingomyelinase in this disease acids
finger myelinase activity is compromised
due to a genetic mutation
that is why swingomyelin cannot be
broken down and it builds up inside the
lysosome
in case of cholesterol transport there
are two Gene products of npc1 and npc2
genes which help in the membrane
transport of cholesterol from the
lysosome and in this disease there is a
mutation that means this particular
enzymes are compromised and cholesterol
transport is impaired
so in type
in in the first type of pneumonpix
disease the sphingomyeline
phosphodiesterase 1 or smpd1 Gene is
mutated
and it leads to the formation of
sphingomyelinase actually normal
situation so obviously once
sphingomyelinase is not produced
it is the sphingomyeline is not broken
down and it is accumulated in the
lysosome and this is the type A and type
B nemanpix disorder also known as npda
and npdp in case of type c the npc1 gene
products are not formed properly which
lead to a impaired cholesterol transport
so we talked about the classification
so let's talk about the pathology of
type A and type B nemanpix Disorder so
generally when cells die or cells get
apoptysis then there are macrophages
which can pick up the dead cell
generally normal cells finger myelin is
a component of plasma membrane
so when macrophage takes it up the
lysosomes inside the macrophages can
actually break down this sphingomyelin
into
into its general form so obviously it is
done by sphingomyelinase enzyme
so sphingomyelinase is disrupted in case
of pneumonic disease as a result
sphingomyelin builds up inside the
lysosome and that is the lysosomal
storage disorder nement type A and type
B
so in NPD Type A
the entirety of the
sphingomyelinase enzyme is compromised
the activity of the enzyme is entirely
compromised whereas in type B it's
partially compromised so there are still
residual activities that is why NPD type
B is considered to be less severe
compared to type a
so
now we have to understand the complete
and partial absence of the enzyme
activity in this context but anyway the
sphingomyeline catabolism is abrogated
in both these cases
so once we delve deeper into the
pathology we would understand that it
can affect liver spleen lung brain and
many other regions of the body
so generally these macrophages which are
having high level of sphingomyeline in
their lysosomes shows a kind of like
fatty linen appearance in a histological
section and they are termed as
foam cells
now let's talk about the NPD type A so
onset is pretty early in the life and
it's life-threatening signs and symptom
include most prominently hepatospin
splenomegaly that means enlargement of
the liver and the spleen other than that
there is feeding difficulties
pore reflexes poor muscle tone lung and
intestinal disorders
and ultimately in many cases the cherry
red spot in the macula can be visualized
on eye examination
so npda is quite severe compared to npda
NPD B the onset can happen anytime in
the life and the severity is less than
in PDA remember in npdb there is
residual amount of this sphingomyelinase
activity
anyway the signs and symptoms also
include hepatosplenomegaly lung problems
thrombocytopenia that means level of
platelets goes down in the blood which
would lead to easy bruising and bleeding
also there are other symptoms like
delayed growth bone problems anemia
visceral organ involvement Etc
now let's talk about the Neiman type c
nemanpic type c
so in this case the cholesterol
transport is abrogated so the
cholesterol is transported within the
body majorly in form of LDL
so here is LDL and ldlr on a cell
so there is receptor mediated
endocytosis and here is the endosome
generally Rd endosome gets converted
into late endosome which eventually fuse
with the lysosome to form the
endolysosome
so in the endolysis from the
endolysosome the cholesterol is kind of
recycled back into the membrane where
they are required for the plasma
membrane
so this is happening with the help of
two Gene products in pc1 and npc2
so obviously these are important for
cholesterol transport to the membrane
but in case of Neiman Peak type c
disorder these enzymes are not produced
due to the gene mutation
as a result cholesterol cannot be
transported efficiently into the
membrane and they accumulate inside the
endolysosome and that is an impairment
in the cholesterol transport pathway
which lead to the major pathological
symptoms in Neiman Peak type c
so there are a lot of neurological
symptoms that happen in Neiman Peak type
c including Ataxia dystonia that means
involuntary muscle contraction that
cause twisting and repetitive movements
then there could be dysartria that means
difficulty in speech there could be also
Caesars which are abnormal uh
hyperactivity of the brain
so hepatosplenomegaly is common in all
types of neem and pigs disorder
now hepatomegaly leads to disrupted bile
flow which leads to the which allows the
bilirubin to accumulate in the blood
which can eventually lead to neonatal
jaundice
then the platelets get trapped in the
spleen that can lead to easy bruising
and bleeding related problems
now the onset of type c Neman Peak
disorder can be early onset which is
accompanied by decreased muscle tone
delay in motor Milestones childhood
onset which which can be accompanied
with clumsiness learning difficulties
unsteady gait difficulty in swallowing
and sometimes with seizures
and in case of teenage onset which is
rare but psychiatric symptoms appear
first cognitive development and
cognitive decline is pretty prominent in
this case
when it comes to the inheritance pattern
of Neiman picks disease it's a autosomal
recessive inheritance pattern that means
if both the parents are carrier and that
means one allele of these parents are
mutated then there is a 25 percent of
the chance there would be affected child
in the Next Generation
so when come to the uh diagnosis of this
disease
blood test to detect the enzyme
activities is one of the way to get some
idea about this disease pathology
then the confirmatory test is basically
genetic testing testing for the
mutations of NPC uh and smpd1 Gene and
lastly clinical examination can give us
some idea
there is no cure and the treatment is
basically treating the symptoms so
supportive care is the key to treat this
particular disease or manage the
symptoms of this particular disease so I
hope this was useful
if this video was useful give it a quick
thumbs up and please visit our Facebook
page or Instagram page links are
provided in the description support our
Channel using super thanks see you in
next video
[Music]